[Music]
hey honey you are having a moment and
you just look so
too cool for school oh my goodness thank
you you too you look gorgeous let me yo
can we please see and appreciate oh i
know nails my my nail artist is so
amazing juan made these in a night i was
like i'd feel like something with roses
and the dress has buckles and he was
like what about these i was like why are
you made like that
i could never ever in a million years
neither could i and i definitely
couldn't rock them and i definitely
wouldn't want to scratch my eye or well
that's an issue we're going to get there
when we let me get there i had to have
someone take me into this dress i was
like i uh i need help i was like i can't
do it myself but it looks amazing and
you have had quite the amazing run this
year thank you from boyfriend to now
breakfast tell me a little bit about
breakfast obviously we know boyfriend
had was such a huge hit and phenomenon
but with breakfast the video that you're
putting out there what message do you
hope your fans take from
this kind of
cathartic story that you're presenting
um i mean i definitely hope that you
know after watching the breakfast video
everybody feels like
sort of
i wanted to recontextualize these super
familiar asymmetric
gender scenarios that we're so used to
seeing in the opposing
genders you know like it's if you switch
it around it's basically just like an
episode of so many different stylized tv
shows right and we wouldn't bat an eye
at it right and so i i
my amazing director lauren and i just
had this idea to switch it around and to
see how uncomfortable it made us feel by
looking at what women go through every
day and also noticing that we've not
made it very far since the 50s and the
60s when all these issues were um
you know in the way that we're
recontextualizing them in the time
period as well i mean it's such a good
video and you're like oh my gosh i've so
seen this so many times right and why is
it the way it is but you're just
so good at that i love seeing you from
your musicality to still you're acting
you just released a new film as well
vengeance correct bj novak and ashton
kutcher
music acting is that still something
that you want to continue to do more and
more of in tandem yeah definitely i mean
it's
it's definitely um i like understand why
people only do one like at the end of
like a long stretch i'm like okay uh
this is this is impossible to keep up
but it's uh it's something i feel
greatly lucky to be able to do and the
fact that you know these fans are out
here tonight and there's so many people
who are supporting um music and you know
my my journey right now is like so
wonderful to see it's just an amazing
night and i'm i'm happy and i'm lucky to
be able to do what i do and i'm glad to
be here with everybody well keep on
keeping on girl and have you already
performed tonight no i'm really really
looking forward to people i know i'm
excited what song are you performing i
can't tell you
i can't
it's gotta be a surprise i'm sorry all
right fair enough
[Music]